hi everyone and welcome to biology
professor today we're going to talk
about the disk diffusion method also
known as the Kerby Bower test to assess
the effectiveness of antibiotics so this
test uses antibiotic discs these are
sort of small filter paper like disks
that have been soaked with an antibiotic
solution
so using these antibiotic discs on an
auger plate to assess the effectiveness
of given antibiotics and particularly to
assess them against a specific culture
of bacteria we know that with the
antibiotic resistance you can have two
different species of bacteria or even
two different strains of the same
bacterium that because of small genetic
differences perhaps they have some
strains have acquired a plasma to the
antibiotic resistant genes the things
that you can have two cultures that have
that have vastly different types of
antibiotic resistance or resistance to
different kinds of antibiotics and in
different to the levels of effectiveness
and so the distribution test helps us to
tease apart those differences and to
identify which antibiotics are effective
or ineffective against a specific kind
of bacteria or a specific specimen of
bacteria this test is highly
standardized
well you might standardize is that the
steps are very specific as you'll see
you may go through them it's important
that if you're doing several disk
diffusion tests that you do it the same
way all the time and that you do it the
same way as everybody else that carries
out this test in order to compare
results from one test to another from
tests that are done on different days or
in different labs or in different
countries so that you can compare the
results that are gotten on those tests
so now let's talk about these steps of
this method you suspend the bacteria in
a liquid culture at 150 million cells
per milliliter so you have a very
specific concentration of bacteria and
then you spread it uniformly across a
very specific auger that's known as
Muller Hinton and auger at a pH of seven
point two to seven point four just the
pH of the auger and you want to form a
lawn and what this means is that by
taking this concentration of bacteria
and then spreading it evenly over the
plate once the bacteria grows it should
cover the entire plate so here on this
image the bacterial growth is
represented by red so whenever you have
bacterial growth covering a surface is
known as a lawn you can see that there
are not colonies here you don't have
individual little dots representing
different colonies rather the bacteria
have all grown right up against each
other so that's the lawn so you
inoculate the Mueller head and honor
with the cells at this concentration
allow the plate to dry and then add one
or more discs to the plate with a
dispenser
so dispensers are typically metal or
plastic little dispensers that allow you
to push off just one disk at a time onto
a plate in my drawing here I have four
disks so they are represented by the
black circles and different disks will
have different types of antibiotics so
you could add a penicillin disc you
could add a streptomycin disc you could
add a ciprofloxacin disc
you could add a tetracycline disc and
there are many many different
antibiotics that can be tested this way
you can even order blank discs which are
discs that don't have any antibiotic
added and then you can add your own
antibiotic to it if you need to do that
once you've added this to the plate you
use sterile forceps to tap the disc down
typically this is where you take forces
and you put them in a little bit of
alcohol and then pass them through a
flame just to keep them sterile and
that's to keep the discs to help them
tightly adhere to the auger surface
because of course when you have these
plates and the next step is to incubate
them at 37 degrees overnight so 37
degrees Celsius that's human body
temperature so these plates you actually
have to incubate them upside down and
that's to keep condensation from falling
onto the bacterial culture because the
bacteria typically don't like to grow in
sort of liquid condensed water that
drops out on them and so you store the
plates upside down while they grow and
that's how the bacteria like to grow but
if you store them upside down and the
discs haven't been tapped down but the
forceps then they might fall off and
that would be bad so that's why we do
this step of using sterile forces just
tap the disks down before incubating
them and then after about 24 hours of
paths you measure the diameters of the
zones of inhibition and what that means
is you take a ruler and you see how many
mil
meters you got right there and that is
the diameter of the zone of inhibition
so you would do that for all the
different disks if there is no zone of
inhibition right here or the bacteria
literally grow right up to where the
bacterial lawn is touching the disk then
you record that as zero millimeters even
though there's obviously a a length to
the the disc itself it's still standard
practice to record that as zero
millimeters - to indicate that there was
no zone of inhibition and then finally
you assess the level of sensitivity
using a reference table can you use a
reference table because different disks
can have different concentrations of
antibiotics also different antibiotics
may be more or less likely to diffuse
through this Muller hit an auger and
different antibiotics will interact with
the auger in different ways and this
means that you can't just look at the
actual diameter and that's because you
could have five different discs all of
them with a zone of inhibition measuring
at for example four millimeters and
depending on what the antibiotic was and
what concentration of antibiotic was on
the disk that four millimeters could be
interpreted as being very effective
effective or ineffective against a given
bacterium and you make that distinction
by looking at a reference table with the
reference table you look at the
antibiotic being used the concentration
of it being used and what the zone of
inhibitions diameter was and all three
of those things together are how you
make an assessment of whether or not
that anti
is ineffective effective or very
effective of course you will see that
when the antibiotic is very effective
there are much larger zones of
inhibition these zones of inhibition are
where no bacteria could grow and so the
antibiotics that are in this disk and in
this disk they did such a good job
preventing bacterial growth of killing
the bacteria that you have these really
really large zones whereas on the other
hand the antibiotic on this desk this
bacteria whatever bacterial species this
is it is completely resistant to the
antibiotic on this desk
it grew right up to the desk without any
problem and so that's what we mean when
we're talking about zones of inhibition
and assessing level of sensitivity if
you're interested in learning more about
antibiotic resistance check out my video
on that topic I also have videos in a
playlist on some other diagnostic tests
there are common laboratories and
medical settings things like the
catalase test and the coagulase test and
the oxidase test so check out that
playlist if you are interested and
thanks for watching biology professor